yeah I mean just playing our identity uh
I thought we played the right way from
the jump playing the right way on the
defensive end uh you know playing
according to our game plan and that just
helped us TR to pull out the way season
High 22 for you only 11 shots to do it
why are you so efficient out there I
mean my guys find me uh good spots and
uh you know just try to make the game
easy so take good shots and play the
right way and everything works St out
second night of a backto back tough
month you guys have all the energy in
the world how does that happen uh I mean
it's the group that we're with you see
these guys they all have so I think
every post game they do this so lot of
energy and I mean we play together we
have fun so it makes a game fun